I remember one time at an airport I saw
a lady with like she did her hair to
look good I was like I like your hair
and that's it right yeah and she was
like you just made my day as soon as I
walked away my first exactly my first
time I was like you got a stranger make
your day what the [__]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
amazing episode of the careful boys well
currently off the Record and we have Mr
Jared feather in the seat oh yay hey
welcome Jared Mr Jared here's the
question carrot everybody okay when was
a can you arm wrestle him before we
start yeah what if I [__] just breaks no
but he's tired right now you got him
when he's impressed we're laterally
sitting in a disadvantaged position
you're giving me no handicapped yet do
power slap do powers
I will literally kill him tell me when
you're ready
you guys ready
Don't Be Afraid Bart how about you
versus him I already know I'm gonna lose
well you got to get strong program this
is a chance to test yourself
you're
our representative then why are you
suggesting I go because it's more fun to
watch kids get beat up
because you look so young yeah I've
talked about that already
it's the forbidden fruit part of me
wants to but I know I'm gonna get into
just to grip the hand you know yeah yeah
they're just scaring me for like five
seconds ready
I've been going
hey you didn't even do it you said are
you going all right I thought he was
just getting ready I was holding back
ten percent are you going
here's the question when was a moment
all right that you realize that your
craft or your interest became your
calling
oh boy everybody here got some whether
it be business whether it be content
creation whether it be dancing working
out fitness whatever but there was
definitely a moment where our interest
turned into something that we knew was
maybe more of our calling what was what
were moments that either led up to it or
a singular you go first yeah you go
first yeah yeah is a lifestyle it's like
an encompassing thing yeah you gotta go
hardcore you got to be your own science
project
um man I'm gonna give you guys a really
[__] boring answer it's not gonna be
fun okay tell me well we'll start boring
so
um the lack of Forward Thinking in my
childhood growing up living day-to-day
[__] like that I realized was a really
poor way to live
and I knew that if I just heavily
invested in my future in education and
then when I finally realized Health was
a thing my future in health that things
would slowly add up over time it had
nothing to do with a singular moment in
time nothing to do with oh this is
exactly what I want to do with my life
when I found the things I wanted to
invest heavily in I just did and over
time to become better and better and
better and I think that's the way most
people should live if you had like a
moment in time where you were like oh
this is the [__] this is what I'm gonna
do that's [__] awesome what was there
like a slightly aha experience even like
maybe I had a I had a good experience as
far as like the bodybuilding stuff goes
which I don't make my money in
bodybuilding like I said I'm a sports
scientist for a really cool company
um I think when I found Mike as a mentor
and I was acing all of his his tests and
stuff I was like oh wow I kind of am
this intelligent person uh growing up
you know I was Michael says professor
and then now his boss yeah yeah no yeah
he's like a colleague um
beat this guy up dude stop talking [__]
I get it Mike's better you like him more
uh
because through high school you know
growing up for being white trash like
there were times when I would walk into
my classroom and because my last name
was feather the teacher would look at me
be like I don't look at your [__]
face today get out like my last name had
that much negativity around it wow like
like I said they're all meth addicts and
like [__] like oh [__] all my cousins
got kicked out Ruth's family and Ozark
yeah yeah literally my uncle owned a
meth lab oh yeah I know what you're
talking about yeah they just heard their
name they're like oh you guys are yes
yeah literally like feather was like all
right get the [__] out of my class uh so
I just thought I was a stupid kid like I
you know I didn't do super well like I
always liked being at school because I
was not at home so I had like really
good attendance I don't know like a 2.0
GPA or some [__] like it sometimes it
was hard to grasp Concepts oh me too man
yeah then I got to college in langmore
Lane yeah I found that stuff and uh just
realized you know hey I'm pretty good at
this [__] and I'm gonna keep doing it
and see so it was a gradual thing for
you because it was like one aha moment
that led to another aha moment yeah just
like you know investing in yourself and
then that return on investment you know
ha accumulates over time but like
bodybuilding
um I did a show at 19 years old first
show ever
um I won I basically turned Pro
immediately so you won your first show
I'm gonna be pretty good at this and
it's natural too right yeah it was a
natural body wow so you beat steroid
guys no no this was a natural
bodybuilding show also it was in the
natural Federation So what at that point
though prompted you even to join that
show
um
I knew that my mom enjoyed health and
fitness growing up and
um she just couldn't do it anymore
because of the tumor situation
um and I was like you know she wanted to
do this when she was younger I should
give it a shot just kind of like an
honor my mom just would be cool
um and I had a friend that I went to
University with he was like Hey I'm
doing the show you should do it with me
so finally I was like yeah you know the
whole thing thinks he's weird getting
[__] spray tan and getting on stage
and like a little man thong so I
actually did a men's physique first
that's where you wear board shorts it's
like literally you get on stage with
swim trunks because you know everything
else I was a kid from Missouri Midwest
and I was like raised around super
conservative so it was [__] weird
man gay [__] but you know eventually
over time I was like all right this is
cool
um so yeah I was like whoa I was I I won
I looked pretty damn good lean and I
think that I could be really good at
this and by that time I was the the
friend who leads the workouts I was the
person people came to to like what do I
do for the gym how do I lose weight how
do I get muscle and I was like okay
people kind of see me as this person
that can really help them so I'm just
gonna let's go with it and I just kept
doing it over time
get to work for a badass company you
know and that'll help that propelled you
to get your Masters and further your
education yeah oh yeah whenever I
realized I was pretty decent in the
education realm I was like uh end up you
know realizing people really came to me
as an authority throughout that course
of time in college I was like gosh I
could really learn more and more and
more I got three or four degrees now and
uh can help people with basically any
aspect of Fitness that I want to like
wow it's really cool see that's not a
boring answer to me that's not a good
answer because I know that like I'm I
know we have like fans and followers
that's a good asset yeah that have those
kinds of questions sometimes they're
like oh like you know maybe they want to
uh do this for their lifestyle but they
think there's some sort of risk
component or they they don't understand
what the signs are they're like I'm
actually good at this maybe I should
take another step yeah but like to even
know that one you know whether it be
nurturous nature you there are certain
things whether it be your mom wanted to
to to be into health and fitness to your
your situation where you wanted to be at
the gym all the time because you were
escaping something and then suddenly you
got good and enough to the point where
people or your circle started like
trusting you or you would build
relationships with other people in that
space that would eventually be like hey
come be a part of this thing and just
slowly one step at a time one stare at a
time up this like you know staircase
that eventually got you to one place
because so many people are like how did
you get to [__] Z Already without
seeing like letter by letter and stuff
but then to see somebody who's like more
than just like bodybuilding like you
said it's a lifestyle education you got
your Masters you're working with your
colleagues that are that was your
professor like those are like the
realistic ways that somebody gets to
where they need to get to you know what
I mean yeah it's cool because even you
know oftentimes you don't even know what
the [__] you do enjoy like yeah I know
many people like that they're like I'm
trying this thing and that thing and I
enjoyed this thing for a year but then I
just got tired of it it became mundane
whatever it's like finding those people
in in your space and and getting mentors
and like even just asking if you guys
like the style of [__] and you love
podcasts ask these guys questions like
they're the [__] guys at the top now
and they weren't here like 15 years ago
and now here they are so it's cool
because you can find those mentors and
find people who can really push you in
the direction where you are enjoying
certain things and that actually helps
you to figure out what you enjoy even
more because the mentor is like wow
you're good at this thing you're like oh
[__] am I wow cool cool and you have
that outside respect too and that
outside somebody else seeing that your
hard work is paying off other than
yourself the good validation so I'm
trying to get mentors now for real I
never haven't business mentors
especially man oh man the mistakes that
I've hundred percent the mentors please
no legit save me man after the fact they
go why did you do that Joe I wish I knew
you back then why'd you tell me I wish
you knew yeah and that's the cool part
too because like you have them you're
gonna get to a point in business where
you're like wow I'm really successful
and then you're gonna have kids who are
like 25 to 30 when you're 50 60 and
you're gonna be like yeah I'll help you
out
this is kind of like the richest people
who have really made names for
themselves tend to be like the nicest
people that I've talked to the black
belts in the gym are the [__] most
humble dudes ever the guys at the top
are the ones that they actually will
give you the [__] time of day it's
the white belt that walks in with a chip
on his shoulder who wrestled in high
school that's a [__] that's it like
it's it's the micro influencers that are
more Diva than legit people I know that
got millions of [__] followers
yeah it'll be like 20 000 followers on
Instagram thinking that they're [__]
Halle Berry and [__] and it's like
probably Fair
it's like shut up dude you're so mean I
gotta hear everybody else's now let's
hear it let's get them I don't even know
if I I don't know I'm still searching
bro like what my thing is today's video
is brought to you by Warby Parker Warby
Parker offers you everything that you
need for happier eyes eyeglasses
sunglasses contact lenses and even eye
exams and you can shop with them online
or in stores glasses start at 95
including prescription lenses try Warby
Parker's free home try on program order
five pairs of glasses to try on at home
for free there's no obligation to buy
ships free again even includes a prepaid
return shipping label you can also add a
pair and save get 15 off when you choose
two or more pairs of eyeglasses or
prescription glasses so one of my
favorite things about Warby Parker is
the home try on program because a lot of
times you know you're stuck at the store
and you're like dang I don't want to buy
this mini I want to narrow it down to
one or two that I like but you wish you
can go and pair it with some of your
other clothes and for me I already kind
of generally know the shape of
sunglasses that I like and usually I'm
just trying to switch colors so with the
try on a home program you can get like
three four of the same models and I'll
get clear black tortoise maybe have a
reflective lens or like a smoky lens and
I get to just try on a really dial in
what I like and if you prefer shopping
in stores they have over 190 retail
locations try five pairs of glasses at
home for free at warbyparker.com off the
Record so like I think so so I think
when I hear this question it's usually
from people that haven't launched like
they have a failure to launch and they
have so many things that they want to do
or they don't even know what they want
to do and then
um they go how do you do it and I'm like
I don't [__] know like I just choose
something I have the flavor of the month
or the year and I obsessively do it
until I satisfied and then so
all the things that I've got into like I
don't even know if I have that one thing
like you know I guess you guys could
identify as dance and you've made a name
through dance and you've been through
the uh whole like system and the
authority and then the the the there's
like a whole
thing around it everything that I've
done there's not really like a governing
force or any type of way to measure it
objective well maybe even more of a
crazy story then because obviously
there's a very clear example that comes
to mind for you uh in my understanding
of even things like like JK films and JK
news like yeah not having a governing or
or concept of like this is a way to do
something and then still being full
force and being like this is what we do
you know what I mean this is what I do
this is what we're gonna keep pushing
regardless without any [__] mentors
in front of us you know and being the
almost inaugural generation like that's
that's probably even more risky and
crazy you know what I'm saying yeah I
think a really good aha moment for
everybody listening to have is that uh
and this is just so overset but it's so
[__] true
set aside
the fear of failing at anything you're
gonna do and like the launch just
[__] launch it who gives a [__] I
failed at so many things in my life
relationships uh different Avenues of of
school I thought I wanted to do like
[__] aerospace engineering the first
time I got into college I was like this
sounds neat well I'll try some math then
I sucked and I was like oh [__]
something else
um that really is like the aha moment
you you gotta have is that realizing
where the the fear is and then just
setting that [__] to the side because
you're never gonna get anywhere with it
so
what you got
was it your first cauliflower
oh [__] it's it's getting there Mom
looking not even it just I just blew up
one day no I think I was always in like
into fitness I was always into like
martial arts growing up and then as soon
as like I finished high school I was
like I want to fight I want like an
affinity for it I started training and
then
like what you said somebody was like oh
you're pretty good at this you should do
this next like so because I was I'm very
not very confident at all I was always
like oh you think so oh geez like I was
like that I still am kind of insane man
okay thank you okay mister if you think
so yeah yeah yeah so people like you
should fight and I was like oh really
you think okay and they're like oh okay
you did pretty good you wanna do next
one and I was like all right if you
think I'm ready and that was like just
how it went on right just beating
everybody's ass all humble not even not
even so your your route is instead of
you having this desire to go full force
and motivation it was more like people
were believing in you and then telling
you to do it and you just followed it
yeah I just would this is huge man like
that's how I got into coaching like like
when I stopped fighting and I was like
man I can't do this anymore my brain
hurts and all these like a lot one of
the parents like I still talk to this
day I remember he came up to me and like
sat me aside and was like you should do
this like you should coach and I was
like really and I was like I was in
college at the time I didn't know what
the hell I was gonna do and then he just
kind of motivated me to do that and then
my boss my coach at the time Savant was
like you should be doing this too this
is how and I just felt like okay this is
an easy way for me to make money I don't
have to work at a regular job I could
just charge people hourly whatever and
then just figure it out and then as time
went on I realized okay I do the
kickboxing stuff the boxing stuff some
people want to learn how to get strong
and I was like oh I don't know how to
really do that I should learn how to do
strength training and then that led to
oh I need some nutrition help and I was
like I don't know how to give advice on
this and then it kind of led to that so
just as the needs came about I just like
what you said was just trying to figure
out like how can I make my business a
little bit better how can I help more
people you didn't settle either which is
the coolest part like you knew there was
room for growth in that aspect of
everything that you were doing with the
coaching stuff and anytime something
arose you're like there's further room
for me to grow as a coach and a person
so let me just keep continuing to learn
which is very [__] important I just
felt like I had I kept hitting walls
yeah I was like how come I can't get
this person to get to the next step like
what am I missing you know so it would
be like looking into other things like
you know thinking about behavioral as a
whole like how can how can I get someone
to not do these behaviors and do these
behaviors so it's like a lot more of
that stuff but without that I don't
think I would be you know I wouldn't
have a business anymore I wouldn't be
able to have a job and it's crazy to
even think about like
that I'm able to pay my bills of this
stuff but at the same time it goes back
to that fact of
just kind of just always trying to it's
so corny because everyone says it but
it's true that like a lot of the truest
things in life are true is just you have
to keep getting better because you'll
always hit a wall and if you're content
with that Plateau then you can stay
there but you have to try to like get
better and do more things and I feel
like um I'm constantly getting into more
aspects of Not Just Fitness but like
running a Fitness business or just
business as a whole because I can't move
to the next level until like you learn
the basics of it so just trying to like
learn more and and yeah just as time
goes like just don't rush it because I
think earlier too I was so worried about
like I need to be here already and it's
like you'll never get there until you do
all those small menial things that and
you need to take and just like not being
afraid of failing is a huge thing and
that's something that you have to keep
practicing like you can't just say I'm
not going to be afraid of fail you have
to like put yourself in fires a little
bit and then just see what happens you
have to try [__] out you know but that's
just kind of my story with it that that
college version of you that was sitting
down with that parent who is like hey
you should get a coaching or whatever
and you were kind of like being
motivated at that time but you didn't
know if you were to take that guy and
look at who you are and what you do now
what do you think that guy would think I
need to be very excited and I I've been
thinking about that recently you get to
the point where you're like oh whoa
you know when I when I only had like two
three clients I was like man if I just
have a full schedule I'd be so happy now
that you're lucky enough to be able to
say you have a full schedule you're like
oh [__] it was crazy and you get to just
farting around in the gym all day and
hang out with cool people you know to
have great conversations with people
it's nothing's better than that but you
know
stop looking like that Ryan why no it
sounds really cool thanks man [__] you
dude [__] you [__] you
what about you Bart
[Laughter]
um I think I'm in the same boat as Joe a
little bit
um where like what we did at the time at
the time we didn't even know at least I
didn't even know
that we're even making funny videos like
I don't even know what laughing was I
just knew we would make videos I did not
knowing what laughing was I just thought
it was an extended cough like we would
just make videos in the beginning right
and like I didn't know comedy produces
laughs I just knew this is a warm
feeling and it feels oh like we're just
[__] around yeah I didn't know we
guys were having fun you weren't looking
at the science of Comedy exactly right
it's like seeing someone like Bob their
shoulder at the club and then they're
like oh you're dancing you're like oh I
am yeah like technically anytime you
move your body to music that's dancing
and you're like oh okay so it was kind
of like that where me and Joe were just
making these things that's re that's
being recorded not knowing what we were
doing
and then
um it made me kind of like think in
retrospect I'm like oh man all the my
favorite moments in life was when I was
just acting funny or having a funny time
and now I look back at all the awards I
ever got as a kid they were always like
most humorous or like like a jokester or
whatever or most talkative like I was
I've always been kind of like a Class
Clown and I'm like oh I think I really
enjoy the Funnies and then so as we
pursued
um like YouTube and kind of start
building like this this like multiple
channels and like a business I think
there was a part of me that's like what
Joe is explaining it's like a very
unformalized thing so I think that's why
I had such a gravitation towards
formalizing what we're doing so I went
to UCB took like improv class I started
doing stand-up comedy we took sketch
writing classes at UCB we took sketch
writing from one of the writers at Key &
Peele to just kind of like okay let's
package this thing at the club into like
okay I'm officially now a crumper or I'm
officially now like a popper or whatever
and then um I think understanding those
techniques and having formalized this
like kind of like Primal feeling but not
knowing what it is I'm looking cool I
really like comedy Now
and then even going Beyond JK I realized
that's really I think what I just
enjoyed doing because even with like the
bottle Brigade stuff my favorite stuff
is making Fitness funny
you know like doing a funny approach to
Fitness or even my favorite moments with
my son is when we both are doing funny
things or he's doing a funny thing or
even in my own Vlog Channel I just like
funny moments and just I just like
having a silly goose time
so I think the time that like I had my
first aha moment is it's it doesn't
really matter if you think you're good
or if you think you're funny right
because like if who knows if you're
really like where you're at but when me
and Joe got called in to do the In
Living Color audition
uh when they were going to bring bring
it back it was like the 10-year
anniversary or yeah something like that
some like anniversary yeah
and then we got to uh perform in front
of uh Keenan yeah Keenan Wayans with his
whole family and because he wanted to do
like the whole you know four quadrant is
older people are older people gonna
laugh are parents gonna laugh are kids
gonna laugh and then so both me and Joe
got a chance to just do a full-on improv
monologue that we made up on the spot
um and the whole family was laughing I
was like oh [__] like what I think is
funny is also what the greats also think
is funny
so I think that was really cool to have
like that kind of like
validation because on YouTube even
though we were getting views and I
thought we were doing funny [__] the
audience thought we were doing funny
ship I'm like but you guys should just
be stupid
you know so I'm like I want to see you
know what I mean it's like you chicken
idiot food right and then this guy that
[__] likes like Taco Bell he goes um
it's good I'm like man you think
everything's good you want like yeah
it's like Gordon Ramsay saying this is
it doesn't taste like [__] yeah yeah
yeah you want someone like oh this guy
you know oh that tastes good okay cool
cool cool and in stand-up comedians that
we respected came to our shows or we
shared the same stage and then we saw
them laughing yeah I think that was a
good validation moment yeah and I think
after that I felt like okay cool we're
on to something I have a better
structure on what's going on and then
I think that was kind of like the aha
moment where I'm like it doesn't really
matter what I do
as long as it's funny somehow
so they could be getting into like let's
say in the future fast forward to when
I'm 45 55 or whatever if it's a
restaurant or a [__] children's
playground or whatever I think as long
as it's in it's a in the funny realm
it'll continue to uh be what I guess
like my calling is yeah yeah and I love
that there's like a a similar theme even
through everybody's different like
stories that there was points and
moments of like validation from other
people that you respect yeah that you
respect you know that like people that
um somehow make their way into your life
because you kept on doing something of
your own interest you build
relationships with people obviously
because you're good people so you have
to build relationships with people and
you have to understand you know that
like you can learn something from
somebody else or or open to that and
then somebody comes in they might just
say one thing that you already knew but
you needed to hear it from somebody else
and then it just sets you down the path
pushes you forward really cool because I
kind of take that into my day-to-day
just realizing how important it actually
was it's literally one of the most
important things but
every DM that I get even though I've
been in like over a hundred thousand
followers and [__] like that for a long
time I will respond to wow I put aside
time on my day to respond to everybody I
don't respond to any of them every
single one of them damn a piece of [__]
I know I need to change my way I think
we should all do that and even just
complimenting people on like clearly
this person uh tried with their outfit
and I'm just like hey you look good like
in the [__] airport like I don't care
because maybe they're pursuing uh
fashion oh so even in real life
absolutely just like affirmations to
people hundred [__] percentage but
that's also because you could do that
because you can like you know fight off
the crane you know what I mean because
they're gonna get mad at him
[Laughter]
sometimes you'll get like an eye roll or
something or something whatever it's not
gonna it's not gonna make me feel like
worse like yeah that's true see my
triceps dude you are rolling at me come
on you see these delts bro it is true
that's very valuable because like like
so Geo calls me a robot because I am I'm
very logical yeah and so I think I'm
learning the human ways because I want I
remember one time at an airport I saw a
lady with like she did her hair to look
good I was like I like your hair and
that's it right yeah and she was like
you just made my day as soon as I walked
away my first [__] exactly my first
thought was like you got a stranger make
your day what the [__] you're stupid I
was like you stupid ass [__] and I told
Geo and I was like Hey like this lady
told me I made her date it was like I'm
a stranger like you're trying to make
fun of her she's like you [__] [__]
that's what people
they were the first time you performed
in front of them
damn you know what see Scott gets it he
gets it dude this guy's winning a life
everywhere
[Music]